bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique la mission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation les hommes du feu et la
croissance économique il y a bien un
lien entre les pompiers et nos
exportations
ils sont non seulement un formidable
outil d'influencé extérieure mais aussi
une excellente publicité pour les
matériels français le problème le
problème c'est que la sécurité civile
française pourtant reconnu dans le monde
entier ne parvient pas à vendre le made
in france pourquoi un tel échec et bien
pour en parler je reçois selim allili
directeur de l'institut français de
sécurité civile bonjour celi mali alors
c'est quoi en un mot votre institut de
sécurité civile
l'institut français de sécurité civile
c'est le think tank de la sécurité
civile qui regroupe l'ensemble des
acteurs de la sécurité
à les faire travailler et faire la
prospective sur l'ensemble des enjeux et
des sujets sécurité civile alors pour
bien comprendre qu'est ce que c'est que
la sécurité civile la sécurité civile
pour prend les choses très accessibles
sont les l'ensemble des acteurs et
principalement les sapeurs pompiers mais
aussi les associations agréées de
sécurité civile qui porte secours à la
fois au quotidien quand vous faites le
112 ou simplement pour la piste monde et
des crises d'envergure tout le monde
connaît le feu de forêt mais aussi par
exemple les accidents industriels ou
très récemment encore la campagne de
vaccination qui a été menée notamment
par les sapeurs pompiers qui ont vacciné
plus d'un quart de la population
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai savoir
faire français et qu'il est reconnu à
l'international
tout à fait il ya une vraie doctrine
française premièrement de l'ensemble des
de la sécurité civile et la france peut
s'enorgueillir effectivement d'avoir
cette doctrine est ce modèle
d'organisation des secours qui est
valorisé à l'étranger à travers
différents leviers et ses pains et c'est
un vrai avantage comparatif on est bon
en quoi les français a premièrement déjà
le feu de forêt ce qui pose ou bien
comprendre c'est qu'il ya une vraie
histoire autour de la question du feu de
forêt de l'organisation de secours et
est donc la france de ce point de vue là
est en pointant à la fois les doctrines
mais aussi damman les moyens qui sont en
guerre j pour pour éteindre pour être un
des feux de forêt et c'est pas et ça
n'est pas anodin si une délégation avait
notamment étaient envoyés en australie
lors des grands feux de forêt des
immenses feux de forêt en australie pour
que pour que effectivement les français
à la fois apportent également leur
vision des choses mais aussi apprennent
de ce qui s'est passé en australie qui a
été quelque chose d'assez inédit il
yad'autres excellence comme ça dans le
monde sur cette approche de la sécurité
civile
vous avez en fait la notion d'excellence
et pour compliquer à définir si vous
avez des écoles vous avez des doctrines
et la doctrine française notamment en
matière de feux de forêt et est reconnue
vous avez l'école américaine qui est
assez différente en matière de feux de
forêt qui est évidemment liée à
l'histoire du et à la taille du pays il
faut pas oublier aussi que que la taille
la topographie la géographie un influe
énormément sur les doctrines dont vous
avez des doctrines anglo saxon
nord-américaine vous avez également des
doctrines suédoise ou allemandes sur un
certain nombre de sujets alors comment
ça s'articule le fait que l'on soit
enfin que la doctrine française soit si
connus à l'étranger
déjà parce que vous avez des centres de
formation en france qui accueille très
régulièrement des délégations étrangères
et notamment dans le sud de la france à
travers une organisation extrêmement
bien huilé entre l'entente de valabre
lnsq helens aux skis et l'école
nationale des officiers de
sapeurs-pompiers qui forment les
sapeurs-pompiers qui accueille très
régulièrement des délégations et cette
entente valable est une organisation y
brille très intéressante qui permet
justement de valoriser à la fois le
savoir faire français qui accueille très
régulièrement des délégations étrangères
dont il faut avoir un outil de formation
qui permet de valoriser ceux là et c'est
cet outil qui permet de projeter la
sécurité civile française
pas seulement sur des problématiques d'
incendies mais aussi sur des grandes
catastrophes naturelles par exemple
alors ce qui ce qui permet il faut pas
oublier que la sécurité civile civils
relève d'une régaliennes et donc l'état
évidemment un acteur majeur et ainsi
parle de la promotion de cette doctrine
de sécurité civile vous avez raison lors
de grandes catastrophes au niveau
international des tremblements de terre
des typhons systématiquement la france
envoie des bataillons de sapeurs
pompiers
afin d'aider les pays qui connaissent
ces catastrophes là et en même temps
d'une certaine manière c'est une manière
de valoriser le savoir faire français
lorsqu'il est envoyé comme ça sur des
théâtres d'opérations extérieures et
c'est une manière derrière de valoriser
à la fois l'image de la france
lorsqu'elle vient aider des pays
étrangers et d'une certaine manière de
valoriser ce savoir-faire également
qu'on peut valoriser derrière à travers
la formation et la vente de matériel
alors justement précisé nous quel
matériel alors ce qui est très
intéressant avec la sécurité lille c'est
évidemment vous avez le gros bataillons
des des matériels classique tout le
monde connaît que toute la population
connaît que sont les camions les
équipements individuels donc ça c'est ça
veut dire le fer de lance de l'activité
de sécurité civile c'est ce qu'on était
de valoriser au mieux typiquement
dernièrement un gros contrat a été signé
en ukraine de plus de 300 camions donc
c'est un contrat extrêmement important
pour l'industrie française et les
différents acteurs donc ça c'est un
premier point deuxièmement vous avez
tout ce qui tourne autour de la sécurité
civile et comme la sécurité civile et
sapeurs pompiers ont une activité
extrêmement variés ben vous pouvez tout
à fait à portée
toute une catégorie de matériel que ça
peut être par exemple du drone jusqu'à
des équipements jusqu'à des logiciels
d'intelligence artificielle et ça c'est
extrêmement extrêmement important est ce
qui permet cela c'est là la grande
variété d'interventions des
sapeurs-pompiers et a créé sa part
confié intervient sur énormément de
sujets dans la société française de
l'accident de voiture jusqu'aux feux de
forêt ou au feu au feu de deux sites
industriels voire même effectivement
comme je voulais préciser de prendre
vaccination est donc les matériels et
toute la doctrine d'emploi derrière
participe pour faire simple lorsque vous
valoriser une doctrine et des hommes
derrière vous valorisez du matériel qui
est associé sauf que selim ben ali ça se
passe pas comme ça il ya beaucoup de
marché qui échappent à la france sur ces
questions là où parfois c'est la france
qui fait la formation mais ce sont
d'autres pays qui vont vendre le
matériel pourquoi oui tout à fait alors
on a on a une difficulté de ce point de
vue là c'est à dire que et à partir du
moment où c'est l'état qui organise
cette cette gestion et cette promotion
de l'un ce tri française en matière de
sécurité civile et bat parfois on manque
d'ingéniosité peut-être de réactivité ou
de compréhension de certains rapports de
force je vous donne un exemple on a
publié une étude sur le sénégal très
récemment le sénégal a développé et a
mis en place une sécurité civile qu'à la
casim que le pays a quasiment calqué sur
le modèle français jusqu'aux valeur même
jusqu'aux valeur citation qui concourt à
l'organisation de cette sécurité civile
et malheureusement c'est la chine
derrière qui a empoché plus de 30
millions d'euros de deux contrats en
finançant notamment aussi une école de
formation donc donc la chine est
extrêmement agressive sur nos sur nos
marchés traditionnels j'ai envie de dire
à nous devrons peut être plus réactifs
de travailler davantage le soft power
encore voilà parce qu'on a des vrais
atouts des vraies qualités à défendre
mais il faut de ce point de vue là
peut-être être sur certains marchés un
petit peu moins naïve et peut-être plus
réactif est ce que le lien entre les
entreprises votre institut et l'état
fonctionne bien pour aller conquérir ces
marchés ou pas alors aujourd'hui il
traçait que a pas vocation à être un
facilitateur vous avez par exemple le
club export qui a été initiée par la
direction générale de la sécurité civile
la gestion des excusez moi pour pour
l'acronyme c'est la direction générale
qui au sein du ministère de l'intérieur
valorise et organise la sécurité civile
en france et a lancé un club export avec
la fédération française des métiers d'un
syndic est la principale fédération de
promotion et de valorisation de
l'ensemble du secteur de de la sécurité
civile et des métiers d'un 110 et donc à
travers cela ils essayent de valoriser à
travers des missions à l'international à
travers des salons professionnels à
travers aussi ce qu'on appelle les les
agents de sécurité intérieure des
ambassades qui ont vocation à valoriser
également et à vendre de la sécurité
civile à côté de ce qu'ils vendent
habituellement ça peut être de
l'armement et c'est ce que j'ai tendance
à dire d'un point de vue du soft power
c'est qu'évidemment l'armement est un
élément extrêmement important de la
balance extérieure française mais la
sécurité civile peut le devenir et
vendre des camions de pompiers d'un
point de vie du soft power c'est parfois
plus simple que de vendre des chars
d'assaut c'est lé mali sont trop chers
nos camions de pompiers non ils sont pas
trop cher il faut juste que
l'appareil industriel français sont en
capacité de faire des économies
d'échelle et ça ça demande aussi une
organisation du marché intérieur
domestique français c'est un grand
classique si vous êtes fortes de marché
domestique et vous êtes vous avez des
économies d'échelle et la capacité
d'innover vous serez plus compétitif à
l'international c'est ce que des grands
acteurs autrichien ou allemands arrivent
à faire aujourd'hui et pourquoi nous on
n'y arrive pas justement sur notre
marché domestique qui est quand même
déjà un marché important pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à voir ces économies
d'échelle alors on arrive on arrive à
les avoir mais fasse suffisamment d'eau
par la l'historique de l'organisation de
la sécurité civile ce qui pour vous
compreniez c'est que d'un service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
gère son propre budget et ses achats il
ya depuis plusieurs années des
réflexions au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur et ses fameux service
d'incendié et de secours sur des
questions de mutualisation c'est un vrai
enjeu il ya des choses extrêmement
positifs qui sont faites dans ce sens là
afin que plusieurs départements
mutualisent une commande et comment vous
quand vous mutualiser une commande par
définition vous permettez un industriel
qui va répondre à cet appel d'offres dac
de gagner en économies d'échelle plutôt
que de faire un camion différents par
département
question innovation n'est aussi bouclé
les autrichiens et les allemands ou pas
hein tout dépend des matériels tout
dépend des technologies aujourd'hui on
n'a pas à rougir de ce que peuvent faire
les allemands ou les autrichiens en
revanche effectivement il faut qu'on
soit peut être plus performant sur
l'appareil industriel en termes de
production et d'économies d'échelle
dernière question c'est l'image lee
qu'est-ce que peu votre filière attendre
de l'état pour renforcer
les gains à l'exportation
aujourd'hui très clairement c'est à dire
est que la sécurité civile tout comme le
secteur militaire qui évidemment de par
son ampleur extrêmement important doit
être un acteur doit être un élément de
la projection à la fois du soft power
français et de l'influencé française
puisque ce qui est très important de
savoir c'est que lorsque vous influence
sur les politiques et l'organisation de
la sécurité civile d'un territoire vous
monitorer ce territoire et donc la
valoriser la sécurité civile française à
l'international c'est permettre à la
france d'être présent au coeur des
systèmes politiques étrangers
merci beaucoup c'est le mali pour vos
réponses l'entretien de l'intelligence
économique est terminée mais évidemment
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
france 24 points comme au revoir
[Musique]